this review is going to be for
Dragonball Evolution ah he hated this
movie I hated this movie with such a
passion sure I hate every second of this
film Justin Chatwin is officially my
least favorite actor
I have not hated a movie this much in so
long I thought Justin Chatwin ruin War
of the Worlds we're gonna get back at
them we're gonna get back at them get
back at them oh geez this whole film is
so horrible
I can't even fully explain it in words
the entire time during this movie I was
just so in pain like it gave me pain
this movie pained me to my heart I grew
up watching Dragonball Z I've seen every
single episode cry mostly and I've seen
every episode of Dragon Ball I know
everything about Dragon Ball Dragon Ball
Z is my favorite anime I've read the
manga I've watched the shows I know
everything about Dragon Ball and I've
come to realize that the creators of
Dragonball Evolution I don't even know
if they even watched any of Dragon Ball
first of all in Dragon Ball - OH
Goku is a little like ten-year-old boy
who's never met another human in his
life besides his grandpa and when he
first meets boma he's like what are you
he has no idea what a girl is he's like
where's your tail and it's hilarious and
awesome
he's completely socially inept he has no
training with humans it's so hilarious
and original this movie makes him like
some depressed like Punk from school who
has a crush on a girl and who like you
know gets bullied and stuff and they
ruined this film the maker of this James
Wong the director needs to quit
Hollywood right now I'm serious
I think he directed final destination
and unfortunately he was very very
prolific as a writer on the x-files
television show one of my favorite TV
shows what in the world is he doing with
all of that training he's had this
movies a piece of crap this movie I
can't even call it a movie this thing is
like a degraded turd crap that's been
sitting on the desert ground baking in
the Sun for years this might be the
worst movie I've ever seen in my life
I'm not sure this movie goku is like
some depressed teenager who goes to
school he's just turning 18 you has a
crush on chichi this girl and all these
kids are bullying him and then he learns
of some you have to collect all the
dragonballs before the eclipse otherwise
piccolo will become all-powerful which
by the way has nothing to do with the
show it's like the directors they were
going for it's like they just made
Street Fighter 8 that's what it seems
like this movie is just another corny
movie or Mortal Kombat 3 or something
where there's like people with crazy
hairstyles and tight outfits and they do
a horribly terribly choreographed karate
it's awful the special effects are
crappy as heck there's a part where
there's a lava pool and they have to get
across it and there's these aliens that
are attacking them but which by the way
have no basis from the original manga
and go who slices up the aliens and
throws them on into the lava to create a
bridge to walk across oh the delivery of
everything Justin Chatwin is a terrible
actor you can make the excuse that it's
the script you know and I would have a
hard time saying two words in this
script but he chose that script he read
it and I'm going to do this and chose it
in but they you know what that does
account because he was in War of the
Worlds a movie directed by Steven
Spielberg he was under the direction of
Steven Spielberg and he was still crappy
as heck I'm telling you this guy should
not be in movies he is a bad actor he
really is I am a very nice person I like
almost every actor seriously the only
time people uh know me is when they ruin
movies that they're in this guy should
this guy is a disgrace to anime fans he
it and he ruined like every scene of war
the world to you then I'm telling you
every oh I saw an interview with Justin
Chatwin or people were like uh so what
do you think I think Dragon Ball has
reached so many people why you think
it's so probably he was like that he was
personal he had a hood on like this like
all over his face look like some punk
and he was like well it's made a lot of
money a lot of lot of people watch it he
knows nothing about Dragon Ball Z okay
he knows nothing about Dragon Ball the
only thing he knows is maybe he's
watched some of the episodes I'm telling
you he if they would have just given me
a camera and said here Chris you can
make this movie you can make a drug mozi
movie I would have written a script so
much better I would have filmed a movie
so much better and I would never in the
world choose Justin Chatwin to play and
they got chow yun-fat playing Master
Roshi and he didn't bother me at all but
I mean you know he seemed like he was
trying to have fun a bit nearly every
line that Emily Rosen says Balma sounded
audio dubbed and whoever plays Yamcha
please please stop being in movies
because you are I was terrible
Oh every character gets introduced by
some wait line that is horrible it isn't
there like like oh what's your name my
name is Yaya Yaya
oh this is the worst movie I've seen all
year the worst movie I've maybe seen in
my life it's a disgrace to film it's a
disgrace to the original manga I hate
this movie I hate this movie so much
please never see this film thank
goodness that opened it like number
seven and then went straight out of the
box office so they can realize that Hey
well I guess we stink I guess we
completely failed at everything we were
trying to do because it's very obvious
the only thing they're trying to do was
make money and they failed and you know
what I am very glad they did I mean I
know this is people's jobs and you know
what I mean that's fine I have no
problem with that but please stop
disgracing things that are dear to my
childhood okay because it's painful to
watch
there were probably a lot of people who
saw that movie and were like I knew that
Dragon Ball Z it was stupid this whole
time and now I'm just now it's just
confirmed please if anyone sees this
movie and it's like what a dragon ball
must be horrible it's not it's amazing
it's like a classic anime please do not
base this film on your judgment of that
cartoon of that anime because wow I
seriously I need to stop this review
right now actually because I'm getting
incredibly mad thinking about this movie
it's horrible oh please never see it
bottom line is never watch this piece of
crap this film is like a piece of bird
poop smeared across someone's face it's
that repulsive never watch it please
take my word for it I give Dragonball
Evolution no stars that's right not even
a half little star this film gets
nothing this film has nothing I will
give it nothing I hate this movie it
took away 85 minutes of my life that
seemed like the longest 85 minutes ever
I hate this
I hate it so much I cannot emphasize how
much hatred I have for this film I would
like to burn every copy of this movie it
should not exist that's it